this year we're going to be bringing a
demonstration to Davos and I'm very
excited to say that it's going to be the
only interactive demo in the main hall
of the congress center and the demo is
called sarah which stands for socially
aware robot assistant and sarah whom you
see on the screen here is a virtual
personal assistant who's going to help
attendees at Davos find sessions that
match their interests and find people
who would be interesting and helpful to
them she's going to talk to them and
over the course of that conversation
pursue two goals simultaneously one is
to build a relationship with them and
the second is to use that relationship
as a way of eliciting information about
their goals for Davos so that she can
better help them achieve those goals
you
[Music]